[Music]
oh
hey
foreign
[Music]
my
so
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
[Applause]
thank you very much everybody please
[Music]
so welcome to our cabinet meeting and
every member of my cabinet is working
tirelessly to defeat
the invisible enemy that should have
never happened to our country should
have never happened to the world
it's a disgrace it could have been
stopped at the source
if they decided not to do that that
we're going to safely
reopen our country and our economy and
it's happening very rapidly
and it's happening interestingly when
numbers are
actually going down you look at florida
the state of florida
a great job you look at georgia you look
at others
they're open and some are doing
extremely well
far beyond what people thought and the
numbers are going down
the numbers that we have been talking
about for the last two months are
actually going down
so it's really terrific in our drive to
crush the virus the u.s has
completed nearly 12 million tests and
that test that number today is
almost 14 million nobody's close
germany would be second with
approximately 10 million less than us
and we also have the best tests south
korea is doing very well but we're at 14
million and they're at numbers that are
very small by comparison what has been
done with testing
what's been done with ventilators what's
been done with the distribution of
product has been
incredible we've made a lot of governors
look very good
we've actually made all of the governors
look very good some have done a good job
but we've made them all look very good
we got them equipment and they got them
their gowns and
their ventilators and their tests like
nobody would have thought possible
vaccines are moving quickly into phase
one and phase two trials
and trials of dozens of therapies and
cures are underway
and we're making tremendous strides with
therapies cures and vaccines i think
we're way ahead of schedule
and you probably heard logistically we
have our military engaged
and as soon as we have whatever it is
that we're going to have whether it's
therapeutic or vaccine it will be
distributed
very rapidly our military is ready to go
they can deploy hundreds of thousands of
men and women a day
now what they're going to be doing is
they're going to be doing the vaccine
which we
are geared up for even before we have it
but the chances of us having it are
extraordinary
secretary azar will update us on all
that we're doing
to safeguard americans be talking in a
second
to protect our people and defeat the
virus we must also
defend the health of our nation's
economy
secretary mnuchin will report on the
economic recovery efforts and the good
numbers that are being produced ahead of
schedule
secretary carson will update us on the
white house opportunity and
revitalization council
and ben you've done a fantastic job they
appreciate it
he's looked at hud much differently than
people that would have been in the pure
real estate
business and he has a way of seeing
things that's different and really good
for our country
and ben's working on uh very hard
different plans to restore health and
prosperity to disadvantage and minority
communities and that's really working
out well one of the things we're very
proud of is opportunity zones
tim scott of south carolina came to me
with a proposal
and a few people understand how
successful the opportunity zones have
been it's a great tribute to tim
and to others in the senate that helped
us with that the pandemic has
shown once again the vital importance of
economic independence and bringing
supply chains back
from china and other countries i
probably got elected one of the primary
reasons was that
make america great again america first
call it whatever you want
but we went way out of bounds we build a
car and we go to 12 countries
to build a car i want to build a car
from one country
we make the parts to achieve this goal
we've slashed red tape and bureaucracy
and unleashed the largest industrial
mobilization
since world war ii especially when it
comes to
big things like a ventilator it's a very
big
clumsy highly sophisticated product
and we have now assembly lines where the
talk of the world we're
supplying them to other countries we're
helping other countries that are going
through this plague
and they're never going to be able to do
ventilators
so we are it's really been an incredible
thing what's happened it's the biggest
mobilization since
world war ii and we're fighting for the
livelihoods of american workers and we
must continue to cut through every
piece of red tape that stands in our way
and that's why this is such an exciting
meeting beyond being a cabinet meeting
which is always good
because with millions of americans
forced out of work by the virus
it's more important than ever to remove
burdens that destroy american jobs
in a few minutes i will sign an
executive order instructing federal
agencies to
use any and all authority to waive
suspend and eliminate unnecessary
regulations that impede economic
recovery and we want to leave it that
way
we want to leave it that way in some
cases we won't be able to
but in other cases we will and you've
heard me say many times i've said and
i've said it very strongly
that regulations we've done more
regulation cutting
than any president in history whether
they're there for
four years eight years or in one case
more
we've done more regulation cutting i
don't mean just in a year or two years i
mean
in the three and a half years that we've
been here we've cut
far more regulations by a factor of a
lot
than any other administration any other
presidency so
that's really something i'm directing
agencies to review
the hundreds of regulations we've
already suspended
in response to the virus and make these
suspensions permanent where possible
i'm also instructing agencies to use the
emergency authorities to speed up
regulation cuts
or new rules that will create jobs and
prosperity
and get rid of unnecessary rules and
regulations
we had cases where it would take 20
years to build a highway
you'd have to go through various
agencies to get the same permit
i lived with it in the private sector so
i know it better than anybody
where you go years and years and years
to build a simple roadway or a simple
building
and it would end up costing an absolute
fortune many many times what it should
cost
and it would take years before you could
even seek
final approval five years seven years 20
years 21 years a
certain highway built recently a small
highway i would call it a road
21 years to get it approved and then by
the time they get it approved
it costs a hundred times more in some
cases
numbers that you wouldn't even believe
we're getting rid of all of that we're
down
now on roads working with elaine and
department of transportation we're down
to a two-year period we want to see if
we can do better
we have roads in there for 18 17
20 21 years over the years i'm not
blaming
elaine for that i'm just saying over the
years there have been roads that have
gone through a process for
many years roads and highways so we're
going to be
getting it down to a year and maybe it's
not going to get passed for
environmental reasons or safety reasons
but we're going to know quickly but if
it does pass it's going to happen
fast acting omb director soon to be
permanent director where is russ
did you hear what i said soon to be
permanent director okay
that's a big statement some people would
say that's big news he's done a
fantastic job
so congratulations well we have to get
him to approve
we'll give you a congratulations just
prior to approval right
so you're doing great thank you very
much so acting
omb director rusev will present details
on
this effort and uh we'll go into that so
russ has uh
done a great job on exactly what where
he used to come into my office and
say uh i think we can cut a lot of
different things in terms of regulation
and russ i think also very importantly
we'll have a better product it's
actually going to give us a better
result
and we're adhering to environmental
the environmental impact studies and all
of the other things we have to do to get
these
permits but so russ vote thank you very
much
i want to once again thank every member
of the cabinet for your commitment to
helping our nation
reopen to recover and rebuild i'd like
to
now ask a man who's done a fantastic job
as the head of the task force
he's worked literally i mean i think
literally 24 hours a day
sometimes to make sure everything's gone
well
today we had a really great article
by rich lowery who talked about the
tremendous job that we've done in terms
of the task force in terms of
the corona virus and getting things
going and getting people what they need
whether it's ventilators testing or many
other things
and i appreciated that article very much
because
there's been a very false narrative
people have no idea what an incredible
job the people in federal government
have done and that includes generals and
admirals
and lots of others so i want to thank
mike pence for the great job you've done
mike and please say a few words
mr president and um
i think everyone around this cabinet
knows that uh from the first day of this
administration you made it clear that
you have no higher priority
than the safety and security of the
american people
in january when you took the
unprecedented action of suspending all
travel from china
before there was a single case of
community transmission
in the united states it is inarguable
mr president that your decision bought
us a critical amount of time
to stand up a national response
all across this country at the same time
in january you stood up the white house
coronavirus
the task force and over the course of
february you began to suspend more
travel established screening
at more than 11 airports around the
united states again with the priority
of of of protecting the health and
safety of the american people and from
the first day mr president that you
asked me to
lead the white house coronavirus task
force we have
we have focused on the health of the
american people
it would be on march 15th at your
direction
uh that we released the
uh the white house uh coronavirus
guidelines for america we asked a lot
of the american people and the american
people
responded 15 days would become 45 days
and in that time it was our objective mr
president
as you made clear to save lives
to slow the spread to flatten the curve
and because of what the american people
did
because of the direction that you gave
and all the dedicated members
at hhs and fema and all of those around
this table who served on the task force
because of the partnership
that you forged with every governor of
both political parties across the
country
we've made great progress that being
said mr president i know that
you believe as we all do the one life
lost is too many
and and we grieve today for the loss of
more than 90
000 americans to the coronavirus
at a time like this the first cabinet we
meeting that we have had
since the advent of this epidemic
it's important to remember that when we
asked the american people to make all of
those sacrifices
the estimates before you were that if we
did nothing we could lose between
1 million and 2.2 million american lives
and in fact even by taking the steps
that we took
the estimates were still clear that even
if we flattened the curve that we could
still lose a hundred thousand
to two hundred and forty thousand
americans
and so while we grieve the loss of those
more than ninety thousand americans and
their families are on our hearts today
we recognize we recognize the progress
that we have made among the progress
that we made mr president
in flattening the curve and slowing the
spread was preserving
as you directed the capacity of our
health care system
one of the great concerns that we had
early on was that our health care system
our hospitals would be overwhelmed by
the coronavirus
that did not occur mr president
truth is as you've reflected many times
because of the ingenuity of the american
people because of our partnership with
states because of a great logistics team
that worked with the task force no
american who has needed a ventilator was
ever denied
a ventilator in the united states it is
an extraordinary accomplishment
the report that i received today is that
the national stockpile now has more than
15 000 ventilators
and because of the public-private
partnerships that you've forged we'll
actually see american companies
manufacture more than a hundred and ten
thousand ventilators in a hundred days
over 13 billion supplies and critical
ppe were also delivered
to doctors and nurses and first
responders and to americans on the front
lines
of this pandemic and on the subject of
testing mr president
when you tapped me to lead this task
force we had fully
done under the old system of public labs
we had fully done only 8 400 coronavirus
tests at the end of february
but as you just reflected um because of
the public-private partnership that you
formed with commercial labs across the
country we've now performed
nearly 12 million corona virus tests
and more than 400 000 in a single day
this past weekend and mr president as
i'll share with the team as
we're increasing testing the good news
to americans is nevertheless cases are
going down
you reflected on that and your visit to
the capitol today and in your opening
remarks
and in that i hope despite the
heartbreak and the hardship that we have
all endured i hope the american people
can sense
that they've made progress that
as we continue to scale testing all
across the country our
our team with admiral gerard at the helm
and fema at the helm estimates that
we'll be able to conduct
maybe 40 to 50 million tests a month by
this september
but even as testing is expanding across
the country we're seeing cases coming
down and that's
a tribute to the american people but
it's not just been the healthy american
people that's been challenged mr
president
as you rightly observed businesses large
and small
who have had to shutter their operations
we heard from restaurant owners earlier
this week and and with the great work of
our secretary of the treasury and your
leadership mr president
188 billion dollars in loans have been
approved to small businesses nearly 583
million have been awarded
through community health centers all 50
states we have been
there at the point of the need for
businesses large and small we have been
there for vulnerable
populations and at your direction mr
president we'll continue to lean
forward in that fight the action that
you're taking today with signing the
executive order is going to make it even
more possible for us to
to build this economy back again
for the american people and it was in
that spirit that one month ago mr
president as i close
you directed the white house coronavirus
task force to release
guidelines to open up america again and
i'm uh
i'm proud to report to the cabinet today
that
uh our best information is that all 50
states as of today
are partially reopening their economies
and the american people are responding
and breathing that
free air again they're doing it
responsibly
they're they're enjoying the opportunity
to be out
in many states to enjoy restaurants
businesses opening back up the big three
automakers went back to work this last
monday
in ben carson's hometown of detroit and
america is on its way back through a
great great season
of hardship uh it's a testament to the
resilience
of the american people so mr president
you charged the white house coronavirus
task force to have one mission and that
was save lives
to have one team and that was to forge
relationships all across the country
because of your leadership because of
the great work of this cabinet because
of governors around the country
but mostly because of our incredible
health care workers and
the cooperation of the american people
we've slowed the spread
we flattened the curve and we are
reopening america
mr president i'm proud to report to you
that we're on our
way and i promise you this entire team
is going to continue to work with
governors around the country at your
direction
until we bring the american economy all
the way back
as you often say bigger and better than
ever before
so thank you mr president thank you very
much mike and again thank you very much
for
doing a great job so i'm going to sign
this now
and then ben and steve will speak and
then we'll go around the room a little
bit and
we'll say what we want i'd like to
congratulate
rick grinnell for doing such a fantastic
job
as acting i don't think you want to be
permanent so i think you're very happy
to be acting but what a job i think
you'll go down as
the all-time great acting ever at any
position
so thank you very much rick thank you
very much
would you like to say something go ahead
please
uh sure i would just say greetings from
an intel community that is very
interested
in providing policy makers everybody
around this table with raw intelligence
that is not politicized in any possible
way
and i have to tell you mr president that
i have heard from
hundreds of members of the current intel
community
who are extremely pleased with
transparency of their work
and that's what they're shooting for
that's what they want to provide to
policymakers
is uh information that is not
politicized by
uh politicians in any way on any side of
the aisle
but to be able to protect their
intelligence estimates
we all know that their estimates and
they are proud to give them when not
manipulated by others
well we appreciate your great work thank
you rick very much thank you sir
uh i'm going to sign this now and uh
so this is regulations are going to be
cut
and the potential is that you're going
to find regulations that
nobody has ever thought of before
because you're going to be doing it
yourselves
and this gives you great authority to
cut regulations so we've already have
the record by
a lot it's not even close but uh you'll
have a chance to
cut regulations when i look at epa
sitting here and i look at
the veterans sitting here and i look at
all of the different people
homeland security chat i look at all of
the
great talent around this table you'll
have a right to do something that nobody
would ever have thought
you would have the right to do that and
so i just
want you to go to town and do it right
do it proper make sure everything is
safe
you make sure it's environmentally good
for those of you that are in that
category but
it's very very important elaine you can
do things that
nobody would believe in your department
department of transportation
so good luck and i'm signing this it
gives you tremendous power to cut
regulation
there you go ben take that
okay uh ben would you like to say
something please yes sir thank you mr
president
and um a big thank you to all the
cabinet members almost
everybody has been deeply involved in
the refocusing
of the opportunity and revitalization
council
and jared and christian
and brooke also big big help
justice was done during the greatest
generation many sectors of our society
are being reconfigured
to meet the singular goal of winning our
war against this invisible enemy
companies that make betting linen are
now making masks
and plants that produce vehicles are now
producing
ventilators i worked at some of those
plants growing up in detroit
and now the white house opportunity and
revitalization council
which was formed by you to help
long-forgotten communities
achieve economic opportunity will
refocus
and expand to help america's hardest hit
communities
and achieve economic recovery overcome
health disparities
and thrive through educational
advancement
education being the ticket it doesn't
matter where you came from you get a
good education you can write your own
ticket
since your historic tax cuts and job act
billions of dollars from the private
sector have been invested in these
designated opportunity zones which are
home to nearly 35 million people
through this initiative we foster
partnerships between people who seldom
sit down together
we're talking about business leaders
community leaders faith-based leaders
housing advocates investors builders
state
and local and federal officials the
revitalization council which i have the
privilege
privilege to chair alongside our
executive director scott turner who's in
here in this room somewhere
oh there he is over there okay has
played a
a big role in the success identifying
more than
270 different federal actions
to support and increase investment in
opportunity zones
through things like grant preference
points loan qualifications reduce
fees eligibility criteria modifications
and a number of other incentives
and at your direction we're now taking
our considerable capacity to discover
opportunity and drive recovery in
disadvantaged and minority communities
that are disproportionately affected by
covet 19.
based on our work and analysis
revitalization council is identifying
diverse policy approaches in areas
including housing education
technology broadband workforce
entrepreneurship
health and long-term community
development
and under your leadership this
administration has shined a light
on the forgotten men and women whose job
perspective
prospects and health disparities are
often hidden in the shadows
mr president you've been a champion for
all americans especially our low
income and minority communities
and we're committed to continuing
continuing your work
not only to restore but to advance
the historic gains and prosperity many
enjoyed before this global epidemic
your council will not only continue its
focus to bring more jobs and better jobs
but it will also expand to better
fortify
public health services that will improve
medical and social health outcomes
and uplift our most distressed
communities
the american people will come out the
other side of this crisis stronger and
more determined than ever
thanks to the authority you have vested
in in the
revitalization council we will leverage
these powers to heal america's hardest
hit communities
and return to prosperity as safely and
swiftly as possible and thank you for
not giving
in to the naysayers
and to the people who use fear to
control people
and instead giving people hope
not with just your words but with your
actions thank you
well thank you very much ben you know i
had a run against him and he was very
tough
and he was even tougher when he'd run
onto a stage
holding a bible up in the air that was
tough i said that's tough to beat
but i said if i'm ever so lucky i have
to get him in the administration so
that's what happened and you've done a
great job thank you very much
steve where are we and what are we doing
thank you mr president so i'm pleased to
report
uh your administration has been hard at
work implementing the cares act we've
really made
incredible progress over the last month
working on
putting over three trillion dollars into
the economy
unprecedented amount of support for
american business and american workers
and i just want to highlight a few of
the things working with sba we were able
to develop the paycheck
protection program from scratch that's
now
impacted over 4.3 million companies
impacting over 50 million workers
513 billion dollars having 5500 lenders
working and we are extremely pleased
that we have increased the number of
cdfis and minority lenders
and fintech lenders now making sure we
get this
across the country with an average loan
size of a hundred and eighteen thousand
so
this program is really impacting
american workers
working with the federal reserve i have
approved nine special facilities
totaling about two and a half trillion
dollars that's about half of our
capacity
and in particular i'd just like to
highlight the main street lending
program which is for
small and mid-market companies we'll be
up and running
by the end of this month and then i
would just comment on
the economic impact payments mr
president have
really had a big impact we've delivered
over 239
billion dollars to 141 million
americans and i want to highlight we
couldn't be more pleased 114 million of
those we did direct deposit
into people's accounts we did 27 million
checks and mr president we now have
developed
debit cards so in an effort to expedite
money to people even quicker in a very
safe way
i'm pleased to show you what a debit
card looks like
with your name on it mr president now
there's no money for you on it this is a
blank
debit card but i want you to see what
many americans will now get
uh so that we can get their money to
them even quicker and going forward we
think debit cards are a safe and secure
way
of deliver delivering refunds do i sign
the letter again or not
the next time we send money you'll get
to send another letter
all right thank you steve steve's had a
great career he had a great educational
career a tremendous student and went on
to very very
tremendous business success and uh
all of that experience was necessary for
what you're doing right
but uh there's nobody better with money
and
controlling money and handling money so
i want to thank you very much
thank you alex please say a few words
well thank you mr president uh you know
your top priority
has always been the health safety and
well-being of the american people as
we've been going through this pandemic
and that's been our priority throughout
this crisis we've got to get life back
to normal
and we've got to restart the roaring
trump economy and we have the tools to
do that
the right mindset for reopening
is not about balancing health versus the
economy
it's actually about balancing health
versus
health by one estimate the virus
induced recession will see an extra 65
000 deaths
from suicide drug overdose alcohol abuse
in the coming years possibly even more
states are seeing a decline in the
reporting of child maltreatment
because kids aren't at school they're
not seeing doctors and teachers who
would otherwise report
maltreatment in the home environment and
so it goes unaddressed
mammograms are down 87 colonoscopies are
down
90 percent approximately 1.7 million new
cancer cases are diagnosed
per year in our country and if we're
seeing an 80 drop
in cancer cases identified we could
already have 300 000
or more undiagnosed cancer cases as a
result of this crisis
a cdc report found a 60
reduction in vaccine administrations
including for our kids
pediatric vaccinations millions of kids
not getting vaccinated
the good news is that under your
leadership we built a path
forward so that we can have safe
reopening we have
the surveillance tools we have the
testing tools we have the containment
methodologies and resources
we are developing therapeutics and we're
developing vaccines
so we have the strategy and the recipe
to support
the safe reopening of our economy and
for the sake
of americans health and well-being we've
got to support this and move ahead with
safe
reopening you know i mentioned some of
the physical health risks
of the of keeping our country closed
down
but we have here today with us our
assistant secretary for
substance abuse for for mental health
and substance abuse dr
ellie mccance-katz who's a psychiatrist
and is the first ever psychiatrist to
lead samsa
and she if you don't mind was going to
say a couple words really about how
extended stay-at-home orders
can impose really lasting mental health
challenges for us if that's okay mr
president we'd love that
please doctor
mr president vice president pence
members of the cabinet and colleagues
as i've listened to states and
communities struggle with mental
mental illness issues that have arisen
as a result of the virus i wanted to
ensure that governors yesterday
heard these concerns from a medical
perspective
as my physician colleagues on the task
force have been careful to rightly note
their perspective and advice centers on
one aspect of the pandemic
virus containment however even medically
it is not the sole perspective
i felt that it was important to offer
the governors a different albeit equally
important medical perspective
as such i made the following remarks
it is my privilege to serve as the
assistant secretary for mental health
and substance use
but today i really speak to you more as
a psychiatrist
who also happens to hold a phd in
infectious disease epidemiology
never did i imagine the nation would be
experiencing the coinciding
of mental health issues and infectious
disease that my training addressed
the research literature is clear on the
effects of quarantine and stay-at-home
practices on mental health
we know that the longer the duration of
these orders the greater the intensity
of the mental health problems
experienced
we also know that these symptoms persist
for years to come
even once quarantine is lifted the data
tell us that when the lives of adults
children and families are drastically
changed for extended lengths of time
for many anxiety depression and stress
disorders
will become manifest and will persist
these are real health conditions with
potentially long-lasting consequences
that must be taken seriously
to put all of this in perspective i
believe it is important to point out
that
pre-pandemic we lose 120
000 lives a year to drug overdose and
suicide
how many more lives are we willing to
sacrifice in the name of containing the
virus
when we look at strategies to reopen as
a medical doctor i ask that you take
into account whole health
not just one narrow aspect of physical
health we continually ask ourselves what
the health costs and risks may be of
reopening
but i ask what might they be of not
reopening or reopening in such a
restrictive way that american lives are
not restored
of course containing the effects of
coronavirus are critically important but
so too is preventing suicide
so too is keeping a person from being
terrified to ever leave their home
so too is protecting the mental health
of our nation's young people
i ask you to remember that not every
home is a safe home
not every individual can withstand the
trauma of not seeing or interacting
physically with loved ones
not every parent can survive the mental
anguish of not being able to feed their
children because of lost employment
not every child can exist in a healthy
way without the structure and support of
school
we have to take a step back and
recognize the other effects of our
policies
while we contain the virus are we
increasing the risk for suicide and drug
overdose
are we creating a future of substance
use and addiction for millions of
additional americans
and if we are doing those things why
have we decided collectively that this
is okay
we've worked so hard in states and
communities across this country
to combat epidemics like the opioids
crisis
why are we willing to forget those
efforts now or deem them less important
as a psychiatrist i would argue that a
life loss to suicide
is just as important as a life loss to
coronavirus
a family who loses someone to drug
overdose
experiences the same grief as a family
who loses a loved one to coronavirus
let us not forget that all american
lives are precious
our citizens count on us to remember
their health and safety in all aspects
of life
the preservation of america's health and
the health of our citizens
cannot be measured by only one metric
virus containment cannot be our only
goal
no matter the cost to americans if we
ignore the reality of the enormous
mental health strain we've put on our
citizens
on the backdrop of an already
overburdened mental health care system
i'm saddened but certain that the next
major public health crisis of our time
will be that of mental and substance use
disorders and it is not far behind
i urge you to factor this reality into
your planning
and i thank you for the work you've done
thus far on behalf of the millions of
americans
with mental and substance use disorders
thank you very much doctor appreciate it
very
sobering that's tough it's very tough
but we're getting there we're getting
back that's very important thank you
great job
i'd like to ask chad wolfe from homeland
security just to say
maybe discuss the record low numbers we
have of people crossing the border
our southern border in particular
absolutely mr president
i think we are taking uh at your
direction the vice president's direction
the task force
we've taken a number of measures that
protecting public health
uh proactive and prudent measures at the
border
those include non-essential travel
restrictions that we have with both
canada and mexico
those also include continued
construction of the border wall system
but perhaps most importantly new
measures that we've instituted
along that southwest border regarding
illegal border entries
and those are the numbers that you're
referring to last month in april we had
a little under 17 000
uh folks that crossed the border
illegally compare that to a year ago
april of 19 was over 120 000 individuals
and they were all brought out right
that's right and so 80
17 000 cross but 17 000 were brought out
80 sent back 80 of uh those 17
000 were removed within 120 minutes two
hours
uh the rest uh took just a little bit
longer but are continuing to be removed
as well so and that's the first
that's the first in the last 40 years
that's absolutely right
again at the at your leadership the task
force leadership we continue to make
progress on that border
thank you very much chad thank you also
mark meadows who's our chief of staff
he's
been around washington for a while he's
very popular in north carolina he had a
seat that was very easy for him to keep
and i talked to him
long and hard for a while for a long
while
but he's a friend of mine but he's uh
he's going to go down as the ultimate
hopefully chief of staff
so mark it's really nice to have you
would you like to say a few words
uh thank you mr president obviously your
work and the work of this cabinet on
behalf of the american people is
is very evident it's uh critical that we
make sure that
americans are healthy safe secure and
prosperous
and because of the work of everyone
around this table
and more importantly your leadership
we're setting
the example of how not only to
uh tackle one of the most difficult
silent killers that we've ever faced in
our history
but also how to come out of that more
united
and because of your executive order
today
we are not only ready to reopen our co
country but we're open for business once
again so i thank you for your leadership
and it's an honor to serve you
and the people of this great country
thank you very much mark you're doing
really
really well appreciate it and bob
lighthauser is working on the
trade deal with uk united kingdom and uh
i hear they want to very much do it and
we'd like to do it
uh how are you doing well thank you mr
president
we're doing well i'm never in a hurry to
do a deal
as you know so yeah we'll see how that
works out i would like to report though
that on july 1st we'll have usmca fully
in effect
uh which is just in time for the
reopening
we'll have the new rules that'll help
american workers farmers ranchers
and we're we're now beginning to see
some substantial
new sales defer to sunny of course on
agriculture but in the agriculture area
and a variety of others because of this
and the other deals that you've done
but in terms of the uk deal we're we're
just beginning that and we'll see how
that
as you said to me a thousand times we'll
see how that turns out
so how can i tell we'll see how that
turns out through experience
you never know you never know do you
well we usually do and actually we've
signed a great deal with japan 40
billion dollars
we've created a new deal with south
korea which was many many billions of
dollars it was a defective deal now it's
a very good deal
but usmta is actually the largest trade
deal ever made
anywhere in the world people don't
realize the amount of
business that we do with canada and with
mexico
is monumental it's the biggest trade
deal in the world
bigger than the deal we've made with
china most people don't know that
and the china deal is kicking in they're
buying a lot but
i feel differently now about that deal
than i did
three months ago and we'll see what all
happens but uh
it's been a very disappointing situation
very disappointing thing happened with
china because the plague flowed in
now that wasn't supposed to happen and
it could have been stopped
so i want to thank you very much bob
you're doing really a fantastic deal you
have a lot of records and
uh one of the people i wanted to get
when i was elected was bob lighthizer
because he had the record
and really had the reputation as being
the best trade negotiator anywhere in
the world that everybody respected he
was the authority
so i got him and uh you've lived up to
your reputation now let's see if you can
exceed it
because you have plenty of work to do
how is it going with you it takes
four years four more years to do it i
know that's all the boris
the first thing boris did when he got
unfortunately he was better because he's
a great guy boris johnson prime minister
he called me and he wanted to talk about
the trade deal how's it going
that was his first words to me how's the
trade deal going i said how are you
feeling
so it was really something but great job
and mike pompeo has done a fantastic job
at state
and he's been doing a lot of traveling
working hard
uh anything to say mike so i'll just add
that
in the course of this we've brought 93
000 americans back home
who were stuck because travel had ceased
uh state department's done fantastic
work getting these americans back to
their families there's still a few more
out there we've still got a little more
work to do
and we're working to make sure that the
global economy gets back on its v2 so
along with department of homeland
security department of transportation
trying to make sure that we've got all
the process in place so people can
travel
again in the way that they did before
this virus hit this entire world good
mike
thanks great job i'd like to maybe ask
scott turner to finish he's
somebody who's young and strong
and powerful and he's done an incredible
job with opportunity zones and other
things and maybe you could finish it off
and we could take a couple of questions
from the media if you'd like
but uh scott make the media so crazed
that they say boy are they doing a great
job
well thank you
thank you mr president for your
leadership and
you know i was sitting here listening um
to all the remarks and what's going on
and i'm very encouraged
and i was reminded of my time from
playing
pb football all the way to the nfl
and one of the greatest times that we
had was the hub
the last time i was with you i was last
summer
we had traveled to 21 cities in 12 weeks
and y'all encouraged me greatly and so
we finished by traveling to over 60
cities
with the opportunity zone and the
council
and much fruit came about in america
because
of the white house opportunity and
revitalization council
and many of you your staff members and
your teams from your agencies have been
tremendous
and it has been a great team effort
not one man not one person it's been a
great team
that's brought much fruit because of
opportunity zones in america
to the people inside of distressed
communities and i'm so humbled
by that but we have a lot of work to do
our resolve
is still the same our spirit is the same
our fortitude is even stronger the
president has refocused the council so
our vision is broader
and because of that we will not quit
and i want to thank all of you for your
leadership thank you for your vision
thank you for your encouragement but
back to the home
in the huddle it was a time to refocus
it was a time to reset and to encourage
one another i know you got beat on that
play
but you won't get beat on the next one
and we happy we have your back
we were a team the enemy was on the
other side
of the ball in america we are a team
the enemy is coping and i want to remind
everybody in the room and everybody
listening in america we're on one team
this is the hubble today we're
encouraging each other
we have each other's back we know to
anticipate what's happening on the next
play
we have a great game plan we got great
leadership
all around the room it's a tremendous
team and it's called the united states
of america
copenhagen will get whooped it will
but it's going to take all of us and i
say that mr president because this is a
blessing to me to be in this home
but when we say ready break the enemy
better look out
because we're going to be victorious
against the enemy and have long-term
sustainability and a generational vision
for america so long after we're gone the
people that come behind us will be
blessed
so i want y'all to be encouraging and
thank you mr president thank you dr
carson and mr vice president and all of
you for your leadership
and i'm encouraging you here so thank
you
so you know we have a couple of seats
available congressional seats
where i'm not overly impressed with the
candidate
and i think would you like to move to a
little different section of the united
states because i could guarantee
this guy would be in congress in about
two minutes
and you know i know somebody that knew
scott from the nfl i said what kind of a
player was he he
said he was fast but more than anything
else he was tough he was just mean and
tough
and that's what we want he's tough but
he's got a great heart
he's got a great heart and i've known
him now a long time scott
and we're lucky to have you thank you
very much thank you
fantastic true we're tough
okay any questions please yes steve go
ahead
differently now about the china trade
deal could you amplify on that a little
bit
and no it just seems to mean less to me
because you know we did this great deal
with china
they have to buy billions and billions
of dollars of product
farm product and other product and
it was very exciting one of the biggest
deals ever made actually
not as big as the usmca which surprises
people but it could have been bigger
over a period of time because uh
the potential there is just beginning in
a sense
and it was very exciting
but once the virus came in once the
plague as i call it came in
[Music]
i said how did they let that happen how
did they let that happen
and how come it didn't go into other
sections of china
why did they block it from leaving wuhan
but they didn't block it from going to
the rest of the world including the
united states why is that
beijing doesn't have it other places
don't have it
so why is it that it was blocked
very effectively from leaving that area
and going into china
but it went out to the rest of the world
including the united
states and why didn't they let us go in
and help them fix it
so i'm very disappointed in china yeah
mr president
just to follow up you've been talking
about possible retaliation for that
are you any closer to a decision on that
sir i don't talk about retaliation go
ahead
mr president why haven't you announced a
plan to get 36 million
unemployed americans back to work you're
overseeing historic economic despair
what's the delay where's the plan i
think we've announced a plan we're
opening up
our country just a rude person you are
we're opening up our country
uh we're opening it up very fast uh the
plan is that each state is opening and
it's opening up
very effectively and uh you when you see
the numbers i think uh
even you will be impressed which is
pretty hard to impress you yeah go ahead
a lot of these jobs are not coming back
thank you mr president
canada has confirmed that the border is
going to remain closed until june 21st
10 days before
the ums usmc aren't you worried for the
economy of the border states
yeah we do and we speak to canada all
the time obviously the relationship
is very good with prime minister and
myself and with the two countries you
know canada's
uh our neighbor we have a great
relationship we love canada
uh so we're gonna be talking and at the
right time we'll open that up very
quickly that'll go very easily yeah
please
happen it could happen before june 21st
uh yeah it could sure it could they're
doing well we're doing well we're both
doing well
thank you uh mr president you've said
repeatedly that the united states is now
the king of ventilators and that we have
so many that we're
sending them overseas selling them and
then in some cases actually gifting them
to other countries my question is are
you looking to use these diplomatically
to strengthen ties with other nations
and counter chinese influence in some
parts of the world
no i'm not looking to do diplomatically
i'm looking to save lives
if we can save lives of another country
that's a great thing
so i'm only looking to save lives
probably that's good diplomatically but
i'm not looking at that you have
countries that have no chance they have
no ventilators they would
they don't have a capacity to build them
and we're sending
hundreds and even thousands and we have
thousands now
and they're being produced at a very
rapid pace
jared and his whole team of geniuses
from
silicon valley and other places came in
and they've done an incredible job
so we have them by the thousands we had
none essentially we had very few and
they were obsolete
they were broken uh we're building not
only a
lot of them but we have a very high
quality ventilator one of the highest
so countries know that and they're
calling us and they're asking for help
they need help
so i i i only think in terms of saving
lives
uh the country uh we've gotten some
very unusual calls from people that
normally wouldn't be calling us
too easily calling asking for help
you know you can get swabs and you can
get gowns and you can get a lot of
things but
getting ventilators is very tough very
very tough
because it's a very complex machine
for expensive machine so we've done a
very good job and probably it does help
diplomatically but we do it for
helping people's lives save lives yes
please
please president yeah do you so ford
motor company has
previously required visitors to wear
masks when they visit their facilities
do you plan to wear one when you go
there on thursday i don't know it's i
haven't even thought of it
it depends i mean you know in certain
areas i would in certain areas i don't
but uh i will certainly look at it
it depends on what situation am i
standing right next to everybody or am i
spread out
and also you look you know is something
a hospital is it a ward is it what is it
exactly i'm
going to a plant so we'll see where it's
appropriate i would do it certainly
mr president you continue to talk about
helping minority communities
what specifically are you looking at to
help those communities what actions
so one of the things i was most proud of
was
the minority community and all of the
work we've done for the minority
communities black unemployment hispanic
unemployment
asian unemployment was the best ever in
the history of our country we've never
had anything like it
we've never had so many uh
african-american jobs
ever ever in the history of our country
by far
and we are bringing our country back and
a big focus is exactly that with the
minorities uh specifically uh
if you look at the asians
they've done incredibly well hispanics
incredibly well
african americans record setting every
month you know that every month it was a
record-setting jobs number
and that's what we want to do we want to
get it back to that level
we had to artificially close our country
one day we had
we did the right thing we would have
lost millions of lives if we didn't
think of it if we lost a hundred
thousand lives
the minimum we would have lost is a
million two million three
million five maybe but take it to a
million
so that would mean ten times more than
we lost already
now i've seen hospitals like elmhurst
queens where i grew up near that
i know that hospital where they had one
day
11 body bags in a hallway and they had
some outside
and that they had refrigerated trucks
coming to take bodies away
now multiply that times 10
it would have been unacceptable and
that's the lowest number possible
it probably would have been times 20 or
maybe 25.
so we did the right thing but now
we have to get back to work and we want
to open up and the people want to open
up
but we've learned a lot about the
disease we've learned about distancing
nobody ever heard of social distancing
before
we've learned about the washing of hands
i used to wash my hands a lot but i
tell you right now i wash you more we
learned a lot
and we also learned how to put out the
embers or the fires whatever may come
we learned without having to close down
the whole country
and we have big sections of our country
that don't have much of a problem we
have some sections that don't have any
problem
at all so we're opening up our country
we're doing really well and
most excitingly we're working on
vaccines
therapeutics and cures that are really
moving along at a level that nobody
would have thought possible
and the military i could say mark esper
okay you know mark esper he's become a
very important person in the world of
medicine
because his military is going to be
distributing
whether it's uh therapeutically or
whether it's cures or whether it's a
vaccine
and and by the way i have to say all
three are doing unbelievably well but
mark
and the military are going to be getting
them out so he has hundreds of thousands
of
people that he is immediately that work
for us right now
they're fully ready to deploy they're
ready to
get the job done they'll be doing it in
a record business and
everything we've done with the military
has been terrific
we've had admirals we've had generals i
remember when cry and chuck schumer said
we should get the military involved
i said they are he said we should use
one of our generals i said we do
our generals have done a great job jared
right and our admirals have done a great
we had everybody involved
and they are tremendously talented
people and this isn't what they do
they fight they're great fighters and
they fight
but uh yeah the minority communities are
really going to be well served i think
we are
going to get that right back and this
includes everybody this
includes our whole country but right
back to where it was which was
record-setting numbers
right now that you are considering for
those communities uh
right now we're opening up areas and a
lot of people are
getting jobs i heard some numbers
yesterday that were really incredible
the amount percentage-wise
of the country that opened up so quickly
over the last few days
i think you're going to see some very
big numbers and i think next year is
going to be an incredible year
economically you can never
make up for all of the loss of life you
can never do that
from an economic standpoint however next
year is going to be i think it's going
to be potentially a great year for us
yeah please the fda has said
hydroxychloroquine should not be used
outside of a hospital setting or no
that's not what i was told
no there was a false study done where
they gave it to very sick people
extremely sick people people that were
ready to die
it was given by obviously not friends of
the administration
and the study came out the people were
ready to die
everybody was old had bad problems with
hearts diabetes and everything else you
can imagine
so they gave it so immediately when it
came out they gave a lot of false
information just so you understand
great studies came out of italy on
hydroxy
you know what i'm talking about right
right
great studies came out uh and the
combination of the three
but we had some great studies come out
italy
france spain ourselves
many many doxes doctors many doctors
came out and they said
it's great now you have to go to a
doctor i have a doctor in the white
house i said what do you think
and it's just a line of defense i'm just
talking about as a line of defense i'm
dealing with a lot of people look at all
the people in the room you know i'm the
president and i'm dealing with a lot of
people
and it's a very inexpensive drug it's
it's almost pennies
it's very inexpensive and it's been out
for
close to 70 years for a couple of
different things
right lupus and malaria and even
arthritis they say
but i think it's worth it as a line of
defense and i'll
stay on it for a little while longer i'm
just very curious myself
but it seems to be very safe but that
study was a phony study put out by the
va uh
you may want to talk about that i mean
we could talk about that if
anybody wants to and maybe i'd ask alex
to talk about then
if you would introduce our great
talented head of the va and let him say
a couple of words but that was a phony
study
and it's very dangerous to do it the
fact is
[Music]
people should want to help people
not to make political points it's really
sad when they do that go ahead
yeah so hydroxychloroquine has been
approved by the fda for decades here in
the united states for the treatment of
malaria for the prevention of malaria
treatment of lupus treatment of
rheumatoid arthritis and the system we
have here in the united states that is
once a drug has been approved and on the
market
a doctor in consultation with a patient
may use it for what we call
off-label purposes which are indications
that are not yet proven and not yet in
the label
and this is the right to try president
he for the first time got the historic
right to try legislation for
experimental therapies but that applies
to our existing regime
which is approved products may be used
in the judgment of a physician in
consultation
with their patient as the president said
and i'll ask secretary wilkie to talk a
bit about the va study
there has been there's been some studies
around the use of hydroxychloroquine
later in disease progression uh but we
are still working on some controlled
studies earlier in the disease
progression to see
if we can measure the effectiveness of
it in preventing the replication of the
virus and spread
in mild to moderate cases rather than
the more serious and that data is still
pending but
and it's got well it's got very good
reviews very good from many many doctors
many many doctors uh secretary please
thank you mr president i and i want to
clear up something uh that
the media has not reported accurately uh
that was not a va can you hear him
because i think it's important you asked
the question yeah
that was you want to listen because i
don't even think you're listening yeah
go ahead why don't you listen to him
that was not a va study uh researchers
took va numbers
and they did not clinically review them
they were not peer reviewed
uh they did not even look at what the
president just mentioned
the various comorbidities that the
patients
who were referenced in that study had
uh i also want to echo what the
secretary of hhs said
the instructions i received from the
president were very clear
and that was to preserve and protect
life those of us who have had a military
life
some of us around this table we've been
taking this drug for years
as the president mentioned department of
defense and
va have been using it for 65 years on
every any given day va uses
42 000 doses of this drug
and what we did when this virus first
hit us
was to use every means necessary to help
preserve life
we believed that the congress was right
and the president
signed legislation to protect life
the right to try and we did this in
consultation not only with the families
of those veterans but we did this in
consultation with our doctors
under fda guidelines so i want to knock
down
the phony story that this is somehow the
va going back
on what the president told us to do
which was to use every means possible
to protect and preserve the lives the
lives of our veterans and i think
as the president mentioned we've seen in
many cases across this country
in fact i was on the news the day that
the governor of new york was asking you
for tens of
thousands of doses that's right um we
are
doing everything we can to protect uh
the lives of our veterans
and this is one of the means that we
used
thank you hydroxychloroquine
is used by thousands and thousands of
frontline workers
so that hopefully they don't catch this
horrible
disease or whatever you want to call it
it is a
terrible virus it's a terrible thing
and a lot of people are taking it a lot
of doctors are taking it a lot of people
swear by it
it's gotten a bad reputation only
because i'm promoting it so i'm
obviously a very bad promoter
if anybody else were promoting it they'd
say this is the greatest thing ever
but because of me so a lot of doctors
swear by it i think we can say that mr
secretary
a lot of doctors think it's great
but the one thing that is true
one way or the other whether you like it
or not it's been around for
70 years unbelievably effective for
malaria and for lupus
and probably effective for arthritis
and what has been determined is it
doesn't
harm you it's a very powerful drug i
guess but it doesn't harm you
and so i thought as a front-line defense
possibly it would be good and
i've i've had no impact from it i've had
no i feel the same i haven't changed i
don't think too much
and at some point you know i won't take
it might be soon might be a little bit
it doesn't it doesn't seem to have any
impact on me
but it seems to be a extra line of
defense
and it's gotten tremendous reviews from
some people
including many many doctors all over the
world and you should look at some of the
studies
they've been amazing some of the studies
but that's up to people
and it's up i think strongly recommend
to people with their doctor's
advice and acknowledgement okay okay
mr president say it is anyone else in
your cabinet
i don't know i don't know i that's a
personal thing as to whether or not they
want to answer that question
but uh i think many of them would take
it if they felt it was necessary
i also had a case where we had somebody
fairly close to me
a very nice young gentleman he
tested positive and he tested positive
plus i deal with micah like a lot and
mike had somebody very close to him who
i also see who tested positive
so i think i thought you know from my
standpoint not a bad time to take it
uh because we had the combination those
two people
it's two people in a very big building
with a lot of people working
but uh so i thought it would be
appropriate but it has had
no impact in terms of me okay
uh any other question please mr
president
yes go ahead you want to go go ahead i
just want to ask you a question on
brazil
who's uh yes and third position place
now
catching up to russia in second place
for a number of cases are you
finally considering a travel ban from
from brazil and latin
we are considering it we hope that uh
we're not going to have a problem the
governor of florida is doing very very
well
testing is in particular florida because
a big majority come into florida
uh brazil has gone more or less heard
you know what that has heard and they're
having problems
by the way you know when you say that we
lead in cases that's because we have
more testing than anybody else
so we test much more than anybody else
again we're close to 14 million or we
said 12 12 and a half it's actually
i think close to 14 million now and so
we have 14 million tests in germany if
they do 2 million that's a lot
and others are doing 1 million so if
you're testing 14 million people
you're going to find many more cases
many of these people aren't very sick
but they still go down as a case
so actually the number of cases and
we're also a much bigger country than
most
so when we have a lot of cases i don't
look at that as a bad thing i look at
that as
in a certain respect as being a good
thing because it means our testing is
much better
so if we were testing a million people
instead of 14 million people
we would have far few cases right
so i view it as a badge of honor
really it's a badge of honor it's a
great tribute to the testing and
all of the work that a lot of
professionals have done okay are you
worried that
they're going to bring their own i mean
as to your the first part of your
question yeah
sure i worry about everything i don't
want people coming in here and affecting
our people
i don't want people over there sick
either we're helping brazil with
ventilators we're sending them
ventilators okay they
they need ventilators i'm sending them
ventilators we have so many thousands of
them we're sending them
we're sending a lot of people no brazil
is having some trouble
no question about it sweden by the way
you know i've heard a lot about sweden
and the way they do well they have
you have norway denmark finland sweden
that little group of beautiful countries
well sweden took a little different
attitude but sweden has far more deaths
than the other three you know that right
do you know that
yeah a lot more death many times the
deaths
but they did it a different way and you
know i understand that too
and as uh mike said very well before
there is death on both sides
there's death on both sides there's
death and staying in a shutdown also
and lots of other things but there's
also death
okay in terms of travel
between the united states and europe but
lifting travel restrictions i'd love it
to open
up as soon as it can but we have to make
sure that we're doing well and they're
doing well and in many cases we are but
you know we have a very big country we
have some areas that have done
incredibly well we have other areas
where
the results are it's tougher new york
and new jersey are tougher
people don't realize new jersey is the
most dense state a lot of people don't
realize that
the governor is a terrific person he's
very liberal but that's okay he's a very
liberal guy
but we like him he's a good man and he's
working very hard
but new jersey's a very dense area very
very dense
and i speak to andrew a lot
andrew cuomo a lot we're working very
well together
and uh you know those are the two spots
that have
really been uh very heavily hit
a big portion a big percentage i don't
know what it is it's a very big
percentage almost half
of our deaths would be to those two now
at the same time uh the numbers
even in those two places are coming down
they're coming down very rapidly and i
put out yesterday's statement
numbers are coming down with the
exception of very little
few exceptions the numbers are coming
down all over the united states very
rapidly
very rapidly it's a beautiful thing to
watch
but it's left behind serious death
and it shouldn't have happened thank you
very much everybody thank you
let's go we're done
quickly let's move we come back
you